foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America George Campbell
Ramsay personality co-host of smart
money Happy Hour podcast on the George
camel YouTube mega hit be sure and check
out both it's camel with a K he's my
co-host today Ramsey personality open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five Canada is going to
kick us off this hour Scots with us hi
Scott how are you I'm doing great how
are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
all right so my wife and I have 11 000
in debt
um but we also have an rrsp line that we
have not used since I worked at this job
in about four years five years maybe
um it has four thousand dollars sitting
in it
um I was wondering if it would be a good
idea to take that four thousand dollars
out and then pay off most of that debt
I am not a hundred percent expert on
Canadian retirement plan but I'm almost
positive that if you do that you're
going to get a heavy penalty and extra
taxes am I not right
I haven't looked into it very well I'm
almost positive you're not I'm almost
positive it's like our 401ks or IRAs in
the states and here we would get a 10
penalty plus your tax rate therefore
George and I would always tell you don't
do that yeah I'm looking it up right now
it looks like there are depending on
your Province and how much you're
withdrawing there will be anywhere from
10 to 30 percent just right there yeah
so that is unwise because that's like
taking a loan out at 10 to 30 percent to
pay off your debt okay
all right no problem I'm sorry I just uh
it's not much money it's not much money
so the damage in actual dollars is not
huge but percentage-wise it makes you
want to throw up a little bit
fair enough okay you know it's like I
want to borrow four thousand dollars or
thirty percent interest nah yeah you
know it's not it's probably not gonna
kill you but it's just dumb I mean it's
just the numbers the percentage just
makes you go particularly the math nerd
in me you know and the other piece of
this is the behavior change because it's
not really solving the problem which was
we went into debt and so I want to see
you use your future income sell stuff
side hustles over time whatever you have
to do to create that income to pay off
that four grand and truthfully that's
not going to take long yeah you can do
that yeah well 11 Grand is the total so
truthfully the whole thing's not gonna
take long if you step into a really nice
side hustle you'll do that very very
quickly but the big deal here is to stop
the bleeding meaning get on a budget
live on less than you make be in
agreement with your spouse and then get
in attack mode on that eleven thousand
and um George is right there's something
happens in your brain when you quit
you're you're being wise looking at all
options Scott but something cool happens
when you quit looking for a shortcut I
would look for the shortcut too it's
human nature to do that and you should
look for an easy way that's that don't
don't do it the hard way on purpose but
in this case the the part of your brain
that that's going to make you do this
the hard way is the part that's going to
give you permanent change the other
piece is that will help you step off
this ledge is looking at what four grand
would turn into 20 years from now in
your investment account that'll make you
go I'll find another way yeah yeah
that's a lot of money to unplug yeah the
10 the uh 20 years from now version of
me is going to be pissed off yeah yeah I
mean we won't do that James is in
Raleigh North Carolina hi James welcome
to the Ramsey Show
sure what's up
so a particular place in life where I've
got a year or two left on my education
my life study Year we're both working
full-time and
um we're both invested in our 401K
options and match options with our jobs
and we're we know we're going to want to
buy a property or a house one day down
the road good and so we're trying to
figure out like
do we go full 15 or more in our 401k and
still transit to the house or should we
put like try to nickel and dime and go
as hard as we can with just getting our
matches and our 401K options uh and then
put all we can into a savings for a
house uh like which option would you
which option would you guys recommend
based on where we're at baby so you guys
have no debt in a fully funded emergency
fund already
yeah no Dad's boyfriend emergency fund
and actually a good bit put away up for
each of our 401K so far awesome way to
go well that puts you at baby step 3B
saving up for that down payment and
truthfully this is kind of a Choose Your
Own Adventure you could invest anywhere
from zero to fifteen percent and the
faster you get the down payment save the
faster we get back to investing and it
really comes down to your urgency on
getting into a house
yeah we don't want to put more than 15
but anything less than 15 while you work
temporarily on the baby step 3B which is
the down payment house down payment is
okay so George is Right Choose Your Own
Adventure you could do the do the match
and no more that wouldn't make a lot of
sense you could do nothing and just pile
up a big old stinking down payment for
the next 24 months during that 24 months
you're going to finish your educations
probably get raises and set you up to
make your house buy and then step back
into that 401k with 15 and start paying
off that new 15-year mortgage as fast as
possible
oh that's very encouraging I guys didn't
know if it was bad to go down to just
the match I guess that was what my worry
was but it would be if you were if
you're trying to say back in baby step
two we would tell you to just go all the
way to zero regardless of match oh while
you're in babies
yeah back there where you're you're at
debt but you don't have that debt so
you're sitting squarely uh at this place
where it's a temporary thing it's a one
two year time period while you're saving
for your down payment on your home the
larger the down payment obviously the
smaller the debt or the hopefully you
don't buy more house but um yeah that
and that puts you in a position to to
really go win with that Choose Your Own
Adventure that's a good way of looking
at it that's how I've always seen it
because there's really three options
zero percent and really Stack Up or Do
the match then stack up or 15 you can do
somewhere in between two but most people
do one of those three options I
personally like trying to hit that Mark
of 15 and then getting even more intense
on the down payment but I'm just wired
weird well and you know I would I might
say which one I like more based on how
old I was okay she sounded super young
if I'm in my 20s I'm good we go zero
because you got plenty of time for
compound interest to kick in on the on
the investing later
but again we're okay Ramsay the Ramsey
is Choose Your Own Adventure zero to
Fifteen anywhere in there but I could go
to zero easier when you're 25 than when
you're 55. and you have a lot more to
catch up on yeah and you really want you
want to get in that house exactly
exactly but uh you know there's two
major things folks that we find with the
millionaires that we've studied that
cause them to become millionaires one is
steadily investing in retirement and
good mutual funds 401ks IRAs all right
steadily overtime investing the second
thing is a paid for house
those two are the biggest two elements
that we see cause people to be a
millionaire the typical millionaire we
studied was 51 years old they had like a
million and a half to two million dollar
net worth let's say they had a million
and a half dollar net worth in our case
study uh that you we usually would find
they had like a half a million six
hundred thousand dollar paid for house
and then they had like seven eight
hundred nine hundred thousand dollars in
their 401 case
um and so that's generally how we saw
them getting there in that first one to
five million dollars worth of net worth
those are two big things and there's a
lot of reasons that those two things
show up with millionaires all the time
because a they're both really good good
wealth building tools but B they uh
follow the idea of slow and steady wins
the race not the hair the tortoise wins
every time I read the book never read it
once and they went hair scores this one
nope you don't get to choose your own
adventure in that puppy uh the tortoise
wins the ugly steady slow
not bragging
turtle
wins this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
the Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from trusted locally owned
businesses like Mr Appliance Mr Handyman
Precision garage door service great
company visit neighborly.com today to
find home experts that you can trust
that are available to serve you today's
question comes from Michelle in New York
with student loan payments starting
again soon I'm hearing a lot of people
talk about an unintended consequence
will be a big hit to the economy with
that money going to student loan
payments instead of being spent at
retailers they're saying maybe this
could drive us into a recession do you
see this happening
no it's not enough money
it's not big enough relative to the size
of the gross domestic product the GDP so
there's not a big enough tail here to
wag this dog so mathematically so I no I
don't see that happening
um
and let's just say it did
walk us through us so what
like these people don't need to pay
their bills just because we might face
no absolutely no so and here's how we
also know it didn't create a recession
did you notice that having all these
people having all this money to spend
did not cause a boom that's true if you
had an extra 400 bucks it wasn't enough
money to cause a an economic boom when
they were all blowing it on vacations as
a matter of fact one study came out last
week where Jade and I were reading this
the other day he came out said that uh
like 80 percent of the people spent all
the money on vacations retail drugs and
alcohol wow
and even well I mean if there's a
recession in the cocaine area that's
probably okay I can deal with that if
there's a little if there's a little
crack recession I think we can handle
that part but uh I'm thinking the
alcohol retailers are probably okay they
made enough money during covid to last
them about 10 years oh they made out
like a Bandits on that oh man it was the
biggest remember the wine bottle stacked
up and the pictures of that at the curb
during during the during the covid
quarantine it was like when alcohol
delivery became hot yeah I can't leave
the house you bring it to me yeah and
lots of consumption was a big deal yeah
I'm just saying so anyway all kidding
aside it didn't cause a boom so it won't
cause a bust and that illustrates my
earlier statement that it's not enough
money relative to the size of the
economy to tank the economy because it
didn't make the economy so it won't
break the economy so however what it is
going to do is it's going to put a pinch
on the 99 percent I cannot believe this
number 99 of the people that didn't have
to pay payments on their student loans
didn't pay anything on their student
loans one percent wow used all of this
chance at no interest to get out of debt
99 took the approximately fifteen
thousand dollars per person that it
saved them and blew it and it's gone and
now they're gonna go I don't know my
budget's tight just in time for
Christmas well the scary part is a lot
of people got refunds from their student
loan servicer so the student loan
company here's your 10 grand in payments
back the government will forgive it
you'll be fine they give them 10 grand
reinstate their loan balance and lo and
behold no forgiveness and that puts them
in a real pinch if they spent that money
because most people said well I'll hold
it in savings Humanity has told us that
we don't make great decisions when we
just have a pile of money sitting there
so that's really scary and also people
who bought really expensive cars in the
last few years really expensive houses
in the last few years who now have to
make those payments on top of student
loan payments so could that cause some
foreclosures and repos no you know the
people that went over the edge on stupid
are always going to get caught I did
that once and I got caught so you know
you're just stupid will catch up with
you it's got It's got a real this is
like your skinny dipping line it reminds
me of that one yeah when it was actually
Warren Buffett so it wasn't mine but I
stole it yeah you can tell who was
skinny dipping When the tide goes out so
there you go tide is going out people
that's what's happening prepare your
cells get closed yeah but I think I
think you're safe Michelle from a
recession uh maybe not a personal
recession but certainly a national
recession Kim is with us Kim is in
Tucson Arizona hi Tim welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi George
George David so
it's so I have just so much gratitude
and want to to call and say thank you
for helping um I just paid off all my
student loans
you're one of the one percent yay
yeah and um oh my gosh it's been such a
journey uh it feels like for years and
years and years I was trying to stay
well that's a little like cut off one of
those years for years and years I was
trying to figure out how do I pay off
all my student loans I felt like I was
you know I made a great salary but every
year I'd get my you know W-2 and I'd be
like oh my gosh what did I do with that
money
um and I was just living you know I I
was trying to have a budget but I really
went I didn't do a zero based budget I
just went with like all right if I want
to continue living my life then how much
is left over for paying off student
loans
um and it really wasn't an effective way
of managing that problem and so I got
really tired of it and actually I um I
just I I met the man I'm gonna marry and
it really kicked me into gear on getting
my finances taken care of because he
um you know he he had all of his
finances taken care of and so I wanted
to bring that to our relationship and
have all of this cleared away before we
decided to get married and so
um I got into gear last July I really
got serious about the baby steps and
um in just one year I paid off the
remainder of my student loans which was
forty five thousand dollars wow and
um definitely missed out on like buying
new clothes and uh you know taking a
vacation
um I could could have you know it could
have been nice to have some retail
therapy but
um there were a couple moments where I
did celebrate you know bigger milestones
and you know with you know three three
loans left I took myself out shopping
and you know gave myself a a
conservative budget um and made the most
with it but
um but yeah I just am so grateful it's a
little you know it's a little unreal
that this is that I've reached this goal
but
um I honestly like I've reached out to
so many different financial advisors
along the way and this was the most
effective method for paying off my
student loans
went back in place or or the government
you know stopped the forbearance so way
to go I'm proud of you how's it feel to
be free
oh my gosh
um you know what's amazing is that the
cash is mine now and I am so much
looking forward to this is going to be
the first bonus
um that I am not putting towards debt
and I like
ah there's just something about being
able to keep that money that brings me
so much happiness and like this was so
worth it and
um you know I was scared to stop
retirement contribution that was like
the one thing where I was like
I guess I'll do it because it's like 600
back in my pocket
um but you know those were the things
that I decided temporarily I will make
those changes
and it worked and and it worked and one
year later you're investing more than
six hundred dollars
one year later and I honestly I thought
that this was going to be at least 18
months yeah so once you get you know
what else you know what else I'm hearing
in your in your uh sentence structure
and in your voice is I think you have a
newfound confidence you believe in Kim
more now oh my gosh oh my gosh Steve
that's so true I just oh man that is so
true and I I just felt like being in
debt kept me in a rut in so many
different aspects of my life yeah you
not only kicked forty five thousand
dollars for the curb you kicked shame to
the curb yeah yeah yes exactly
good for all of that so when's the
wedding
oh um there's not a date first the
engagement needs to happen but it's
coming around the corner so but you're
that confident that confidence is now
led into your relationships like this is
the guy for sure oh yeah we've we've
been ring shopping and all of that so
that's all in place wow what a year
you've got I'm so proud of you
congratulations hey thanks for calling
in God bless you that is absolutely
amazing you know when you understand
that personal finance is 80 behavior
only 20 head knowledge you understand
that you permanently change
while while you are getting out of debt
it's a different you on the other side
of it because your behaviors have
changed and it changes who you are at
her confidence level like we're talking
about the shame is gone 100 in one year
transformation it can happen for any of
you out there this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
wash and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
hey guys uh you can help us out if you'd
like you are our best marketing telling
your friends about us and you can do
that by sharing the show share hitting
the share button sharing a link or just
telling people where you listen uh
however you're doing it whether it's
YouTube or radio station TBN it doesn't
matter we'd love to have you tell people
about us and you can use the technology
to do that or you can use your mouth to
do that I don't care thank you you can
subscribe and follow depending on
whether you're podcast YouTube whatever
hit the click button it makes a big
difference if you actually do that
because it it changes the way the
algorithms work and it pushes our show
forward for other people when they're
searching to find it and so it changes
the search engines so to speak and so
please help us with that by subscribing
sharing oh and leave a five star review
that's always helpful too and we've
gotten some really nice reviews people
are nice yeah they're really nice people
out there and the trolls they'll always
be there just ignore them well there's
never been a statue erected to occur
Nick
and not that I can think of so just keep
that in mind if you're a Critic keep
that in mind you may not want a statue
but you just need to know that in other
words people don't admire that
the fact that you live in your mother's
basement and troll all day long I got to
get my mom to leave a review because she
watches on TBN every day oh and she now
sees it on a big screen she says you
need to smile more oh so I gotta
remember Mom you're watching out there
thanks Mom for the media training so
she's my biggest critic right now yeah
well and your biggest supporter so
seriously she's a big fan it's all in
love George that's true she loves to
critique Mama Campbell and grandma too
we got Grandma watching TV in now yeah
well and Mama Campbell's getting ready
to be a grandma that's right wrong baby
we could change her name that's right
yeah all right Jonathan's with us in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Jonathan how
are you
better than we deserve what's up
absolutely so I've had a tough couple
months I got laid off but the light is
at the end of the tunnel and I got hired
last week better job
I almost doubled my salary whoa thank
God you got laid off
exactly so that's what I'm doing I'm
trying to make sure that I'm doing
what's best and what's right with that
and I haven't followed your baby steps
to a t always and well it's time to
start Jonathan exactly
exactly so that's where I want to make
sure I'm starting this job I'm gonna get
the paycheck the first month I want to
make sure that I'm doing this right from
now on good I have uh 87 000 in student
loan debt
and I have uh 27 000 left on my car uh
and otherwise I have no debt I have 8
000 in savings
um after I pay this the rent at the
first of the month I I have 11 and a
half and half after I pay rent and
everything at the first of the month
I'll have eight thousand dollars in
savings so I have step one I need to
build my way back to step three thank
the Lord I had it there during the
layoffs and
um I still have 24 000 in my Roth
um 401K good good and what's the new
salary how much you're making the new
salary is one uh 130. wow are you
married
I am not okay cool good for you all
right so 114 000 in debt eight thousand
dollars in savings and 130 000 income
did I miss something
nope okay
well it's it's simple and it's hard
because you're used to having that
cushion of an emergency fund while being
very unsafe and insecure on the debt
side and so baby you're in baby step two
you keep saying I gotta get back to baby
step three you were never there we got
to step in between that we just skipped
we just leapfrogged it
you can't get the baby step three unless
you've done two that's kind of how the
numeral numerology thing works so
um so so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna attack the debts
and your car is your smallest one and
we're gonna throw seven of your 8 000 at
that and you're at baby step one one
thousand dollar save now we're attacking
doing the debt snowballing baby step two
attacking with a Vengeance and we're
gonna you know do nothing
no eating out no partying no vacations
no spending money
I'm tired of renting I don't care you
need to get this mess cleaned up
okay you're broke
that's why you're a renter
yeah so let's not be broke anymore let's
get this mess cleaned up so you got a
hundred and fourteen thousand dollars if
you pay off uh sixty five thousand
dollars a year
or seventy thousand dollars a year out
of your 130 you're debt free in two
years zero debt at all yo paid for car
and Sallie Mae will have been evicted
from your house
you'll have your life back how old are
you
okay or you can wander along the next 10
years and be mediocre Jonathan and at 40
still be screwing around with the
student loan debt like most people do
or you can punch the thing in the
freaking face repeatedly until it dies
El time to get with it are those student
loans broken up into a bunch of little
loans
um they Consolidated uh but they're
still like consolidated federally and I
think the average on that uh interest
rate is like 5.8 yeah so no adding to
your retirement no life for the next 18
to 24 months and don't withdraw from
your retirement either yeah 18 to 24
months it's game on it's I am so pissed
I am getting this mess cleaned up I felt
very vulnerable and Afraid when I got
laid off and I had 114 000 in debt so
the next time something bad happens not
if when something bad happens I'll have
no debt
it's a different feeling dude
yeah but not having I mean I because I
didn't attack my debt so hard I had that
three months you know safety cushion so
when the rain happened I was okay yeah I
I kind of want to have that so you know
I kind of don't care what you want
you're broke
yep you call me
dude do this stuff I'm gonna be mean to
you do it come on I'm your coach it's
halftime all right okay yeah first first
half in in the first half the quarter
first quarter you you got a little bit
ahead second half you got behind and now
you're coming in from the half and it's
time to get with it and let's get this
thing knocked out you get a new lease on
life you got double your you got thank
God you got laid off you got double your
income and no listen I don't want you to
stay with no emergency fund for long the
faster you get out of debt the faster
you're going to have a legitimate
emergency fund that's baby step three
but but listen this millions of people
have done what I'm asking you to do for
you doesn't affect me man but listen
don't don't sit and argue with your
personal trainer when he's got a
six-pack and you have a keg don't argue
with your personal trainer you called us
do it do it do it do it do it do it you
can do it man I'm cheering you on I'm
not fussing at you you can do this hang
on here's the other part the the student
loan pause is really what saved him and
that's coming to an end abrupt Halt and
so those payments are coming back and so
use another job you owe with many
payments is 87 000 makes up so next time
that happens you're not safe and that
emergency fund is going to get drained
real quick if we don't get rid of these
payments they're killing you man yeah
it's your shortest distance to peace
Financial Peace two words that don't go
together like Airline service okay it's
your shortest distance to peace and your
shortest distance to wealth the the
distance the path we're giving you
please the lady just called right before
you and said how how wonderfully it
worked when she finally decided to work
it so it's tough people go well Dave I'm
kind of doing your plan and I got no
debt except for a hundred thousand I'm
like are you listening to yourself like
did you just follow the plan if it
doesn't work come back later and narrow
it sounds but you can't do half the plan
and get mad when you get half the
results don't call us back here's a
problem George you don't even get half
the results because this thing doesn't
it's not linear like that doing half the
plan gives you 10 of the results
that's what the problem with ish is it's
more damaging than it sounds because you
feel like you're doing something yeah
ish you know but you're not really doing
anything it's like you know you're gonna
it's like the people that do yo-yo
dieting you know you know what I'm
talking about they they lose weight and
then they gain back back and forth back
and then they lose weight and then they
gain back more and so the net five years
later is they weigh more than when they
started considerably and so uh because
they didn't change permanently the
grooves in our brain when it comes to
the dieting people always say lifestyle
you have to change your lifestyle well
that's what we're talking about Paradigm
Shift behavior all of it now the whole
thing so hang on dude we're going to
send you a copy of the book The Total
Money Makeover I want you to get a
highlighter I want there to be like hand
grease on that book because you're
looking at it all the time lots of
sticky notes all through it this is your
guide it is a proven plan 10 million of
these Total Money Makeover books out
there
it didn't happen because it didn't work
those sales happen because this crap
works I don't know how to do nothing
else but dude I got this down hang on
we'll give you a copy of the book this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us America
open phone's a triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey if you're a
new listener and you want to do you dive
deeper into the Ramsey Baby Steps this
whole Ramsey way of doing things go to
ramsaysolutions.com click the get
started button completely free and we'll
help you figure out what the next best
step in your financial journey is
Janelle is with us in Spokane Washington
hi Janelle welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi George
hi how can we help
yeah so my question is in short how do I
Transit the personal baby steps to
business but I'll give a little
background so I found you in 2016 paid
off 60 000 in Consumer Debt and then the
mortgage and so we're on baby step 7
personally without afforded us to do was
for me to leave my government job and
open my own business two years ago and
I'm trying to figure out how much
savings the business should have you
know we keep those things separate and
is there ever a time when debt in
business might like we have a big
project we need to do that would bring
in more business do I just practice that
same patient
and wait until the business can pay cash
for that yes
okay yeah that's what I do we run Ramsey
businesses with 300 million dollar
Ramsay Solutions with 300 million dollar
business this year uh it started on a
card table in my living room 32 years
ago and we've never borrowed a dime and
we've had a lot of big projects and big
is always relative to where you are
right then right I mean when you're on a
card table on your living room big as
anything but um you know we're just uh
uh We've sometimes we just had to say no
to things but then we're always ready
when something like a pandemic hits or
when some other negative event occurs in
business variables that we can't control
we've always got a pile of cash and no
debt and so we've never laid off a sold
we got over a thousand team members and
we've never done a layoff even in
downturns even when we have fluctuations
in cash flow we don't have to do we
don't have to lose our greatest asset
which is our people
um and so we don't have to play
Corporate America games which is treat
people like their dirt and
um so you know because we've handled
done this with those principles so all
of that to say
um you're always going to have attention
uh between there's always going to be a
a shiny object in front of you
yeah and I just have to tell myself
don't be a Bash
because that's okay
it's either personal side that's so true
but a bass you know they jump on shiny
objects and you know what happens is
they get hooked
and then they get reeled in the boat and
filleted okay so don't be a bass because
sometimes the B is silent okay and so
you'll get that one too yeah it'll come
to me later but um yeah that's what I I
have to tell myself that all the time
because there's always something when
you're in business you're and you're an
entrepreneur you're excited about the
opportunities are in front of you and
they all are good they're not but we
always feel like they're good all of our
ideas we think they're good but they're
not and you know so what has happened is
I've limited the size of my mistakes
because I refuse to borrow in them you
will magnify the size of your mistakes
in business when you borrow into them
does that make sense
for receiving
of our insurance deductible which is
five thousand dollars that just sits
there and then I have four months
expenses because it is a seasonal
business so far my goal is to not touch
that four months in the winter but good
but it's there should I have more than
that yeah maximum of six
in retained earnings six or six months
of expenses in retained earnings is
plenty I've never been able to achieve
that we don't have six months of Return
of expenses or retained earnings today
uh that would be like bazillions of
dollars okay today but
um but but the uh uh
the the thing is since I don't borrow
money I have to sit on cash
yeah because cash covers the downturns
and cash covers the opportunities to buy
things to try a new project that might
fail I tried a project 18 months ago
that we're still closing up right now
the cost cost us 3.2 million dollars in
losses we lost 3.2 million dollars I'm
still kind of aching from that but um
because I love the idea I still love the
idea but apparently it sucked so um uh
but it was painful really really painful
and I'm I'm whining in front of everyone
right now but um but yeah but that at
least it was cash right you mentioned I
don't have to pay payments on my mistake
for the next four years
it's over except for the emotional
scars and tears and and whining but yeah
all that but yeah so that's what you
want to do six months covers your
purchases it covers your new ideas and
it covers your downturns it's called
retained earnings it's not quite an
emergency fund because it does more than
just emergencies so it's a little
different in that regard and the baby
steps really do not apply to business
okay because the the principles that the
baby steps are based on do apply to
business they already have money in the
borrower slave for the lender so we
don't borrow money live on less than you
make a foolish man devours all he has
always have savings because in the house
of the wise or stores of choice food and
oil spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land diversify okay these are biblical
financial principles that are common
sense and Grandma's ways of doing things
be always be generous God loves a
cheerful Giver be generous in your
personal life be generous with your
business no one hates generous people
well that's probably not true but they
don't hate them for being generous it's
an attract I'm a generous person people
hate me so there's that but not because
of that they hate me for other reasons
that they made up in their own my little
Minds that's right well I want to help
you with this I want to gift you Dave's
book entree leadership because this is
the Playbook that he's built this place
on and he's been doing it for 30 years
now successfully so we're gonna send
that to you I also encourage you to
check out the entree leadership podcast
which Dave hosts and you'll hear some of
these calls where people got themselves
into a pickle because they thought if I
just go into debt we'll have more money
and it'll all work out and then it
doesn't work out and business gives you
more rationalization even than personal
does because you think you're going to
make money with the money that you're
going down with I mean so that's the
ultimate rationalization and uh you know
if I just if I just had this piece of
equipment oh we could do it it doesn't
feel frivolous you're not going on
vacation or buying a car it's not it's
not get a piece of equipment it's not
consumerism it's actually investing but
it's still a bad idea still a bad idea
and you still get yourself in a pinch
good question thanks for joining us
Janelle yeah do check out the entree
leadership podcast I'm enjoying I just
took it over in uh we fired George
that's right in uh in January because
Jordan he's such a big deal now he ain't
got time to do the dadgum podcast so I
had to go do it they wanted me to do
this YouTube channel my guys I already
host 17 shows around here we got to take
one off there's only so much that George
can do with his stardom I'm a lot of man
but I'm only one man I've been told that
by nobody
I'm not even commenting okay open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five the entree leadership
podcast by the way is now color driven
so people like her call in to that show
all the time and we'd love to have you
do that and uh thanks for joining us and
by the way you can come to the entree
leadership events there's we have about
10 000 small businesses between the size
of five team members and 200 team
members that uh interact with us in
coaching uh we have a digital product
called entree leadership Elite where you
can follow through the stages of
business and the six drivers of business
uh people come to entree Leadership
Summit uh the entreulership Master
Series will be here on campus this fall
there's about 75 tickets left of that I
think it's on we only allowed about 750
coming into it because we keep that very
small it's very interactive and um I
love working with small business people
because like Janelle because they're the
backbone of the American economy
absolutely and they inspire me when I
meet these men and women at these events
I'm going these guys are rock stars and
they're running their businesses debt
free and so it's another reminder that
you can do this differently than culture
says too yeah and let me just that was
not a philosophical statement that was a
statistical statement 54 of the gross
domestic product in America the economy
54 is created by businesses with less
than 500 team members by definition
small businesses so small business
literally mathematically is the backbone
of the American economy so I mean you
know whatever Dell does or whatever
big company does is nice or whatever
that's fun but it really is not the
economy it's Mom and Pops running heat
and air companies and ice cream shops
and that are running local veterinarian
clinic they're the ones in their
communities they're the ones that make
the world go around man mathematically
economically this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell host co-host of the smart money
happy hour
massively successful podcast and the
ever popular brand new exploding George
Campbell YouTube
ah station I don't really call that a
show yeah I mean you could call it a
show it's all Squishy in the YouTube
world now but now we're on Spotify too
you can watch us on Spotify with their
new Spotify video platform well there
you go so we're no longer just a YouTube
channel there's this show on Spotify
yeah video too yeah oh hi guys I think
so oh yeah not yet not yet we're working
on it hello in the future I got there
first Dave as I tend to do you're a
Cutting Edge setting the trends Cutting
Edge just like a razor just right on the
end we're gonna get you in skinny jeans
next more of a guinea pig than Cutting
Edge if you were to put me a guinea pig
heard people hurt people James
his third grade teacher was mean to him
but yeah the um wow he was homeschooled
so it's be as well Mrs Childs she
watches the show so I know she just saw
that burn happen live oh
ouch all right Julia's with us in Dallas
hi Julia how are you hi thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
yeah
I'm retired and I do not have a
long-term care plan and everyone says
you've got to have one so I've been
talking to several people and trying to
find what's the best and I present it
with a couple of them and the one that
sounds good but it may be too good to be
true is what they're calling asset
slacks it's a fixed premium universal
life insurance
no it's horrible
horrible I'm sorry I'm sorry I just cut
to the chase here yeah no all you're
doing is prepaying everything that's all
you're doing how old are you
I'm I'm a 70. okay
um so I'm really late into the game okay
and are you in good health are you in
good health
I'm in good health what is your uh
what's your nest egg look like
um about seven hundred thousand okay and
uh are you married
no okay and they're children okay uh the
likelihood of you if you were to
self-insure at this stage of you burning
through your 700 000 is almost zero the
average nursing home stay is two and a
half years
in America okay and the older you are
the more that average drops for obvious
reasons
okay so that includes from 60 years old
on so 70 year old is probably less than
two and a half uh time year average on
average now average nursing homes about
uh anywhere from 50 to 100K a year so
let's call this 250 000 is the average
nursing home stay if you buy a long-term
care policy it won't cover but three or
four years
right okay and so
you know the the three or four years
it's covering is 250 000 I don't want
you to lose 250 000 but you worked your
whole life you got 700 000 way to go you
got paid for a house too
yes so you're in a millionaire then I
bet right
am I I don't know what's your house
worth
um about two hundred thousand okay and
you got 700 in the in the nest egg so
that's 900 so you're pretty close if
you're not a millionaire you're very
close to being one all right okay a
million dollar net worth and so
um I if I were in your shoes and I'm
talking to you you're telling me you're
healthy I'm gonna self-insure through
this I'm not buying one of these
products I like long-term care insurance
if you told me you had three hundred
thousand dollars in total Nest Egg
um I'd tell you to let's talk about how
to get long-term care insurance but at
your age it's going to be expensive and
that's what you're running into you're
running into seven eight thousand dollar
your premiums aren't you
well the
Universal plan no no not that one here
that one's got a bunch of other costs
built into it okay well the other one
that I was presented with was an
Indemnity which had a home care plan
which was running in like 2000 a year
and a nursing home with an assisted
living for about 1300 and I could do one
or both of them yeah
um that's still that's a bare bones
policy that's the other end of the
spectrum so here's the thing what you'll
probably find and and I don't know how
you'll pull this off in your exact
situation but uh I'm getting ready to
turn 63. Sharon and I will self-insure
through our nursing home type needs
because if something happens to Sharon
with the amount of money that we have
100 chance I'm gonna do in-home care and
hire somebody full-time to live in our
house
I can afford it and it's actually
cheaper probably than a nursing home
anyway
and a higher quality care and if I have
to hire two and a butler I will it's
still gonna I'm still gonna I still got
the money right I'm still okay it's one
of the reasons I work is for quality of
life
and so I'm going to take care of Sharon
she's going to take care of me and I
don't have to be there personally doing
every little thing like like if you know
if someone's got Advanced Dementia or
something and you need you know serious
care I can bring in serious care into my
home it's not that big a deal I mean we
can buy a bed that elevates I mean it's
not that big a thing you know the stuff
when you start talking about writing
checks that are a hundred thousand
dollars a year quickly you can start
hiring a bunch of people right
yes so I this is this is our plan we're
self-insuring through it now I will tell
you again I'm a huge believer once
you're 60 years old and spending three
or four thousand dollars a year for
someone that has an EST egg of under a
half million dollars
and having and just buying a straight
long-term care policy we believe in
long-term care insurance but once you've
got a million dollar net worth or
greater and it's enough of its liquid to
do In-Home Care the Ramses will be doing
in-home care
and my net worth certainly larger than
that but
um
not to brag but the point is it's not a
thing I mean I spend more than that on a
dadgum car you know so I mean it's just
yeah the point is would it bankrupt you
to have to cover the side of your own
pocket well what happens in a typical
scenario is let's say Mom and Dad have
three hundred thousand dollars saved
okay and uh typically the normal
scenario statistically is Papa goes into
the nursing home
and it stays there two and a half years
and burns the cracks and scrambles in
this day burns the 300 Grand up and dies
Mama's left
no money and probably retired unable to
work and Matt at the nursing home but
they didn't do anything wrong all they
did was provide a service and you paid
them for it they didn't do anything
wrong nursing homes aren't Crooks they
do find most of them do a fine job uh so
but in that case 75 percent of you
ladies will outlive your husbands
statistically
now I don't know exactly what all that
means but that's the actual number maybe
we could have a lot of fun jokes with
that but anyway Sharon has our full
estate plan uh based on me predeleting
her I'll just tell you I think Sharon's
gonna outlive me at this time I'm
thinking I have to sleep with one eye
open with this woman but yeah the um
because she get off me and have a really
good life but the uh uh so
but the uh uh
uh if you if ladies if your husband
outlives you and he burns through the
nest egg and the nursing home bill
because you only had 300 Grand safe then
you use all that then you should
definitely that's where you need
long-term care insurance big time you
can't handle that risk if you're in
poverty level you get welfare Medicaid
nursing home okay if you're in poverty
and if you're wealthy you can provide it
for yourself with self-insured but that
middle ground baby you need long-term
care insurance once you're 60 years old
and statistically it's less than one
quarter of one percent of the people
under 60 go into a nursing home that's
nobody
so don't buy this stuff until you're 60.
you don't need it it's not there the
chances aren't there so we love
long-term care insurance in the in that
particular window this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
George Campbell Ramsey personality host
of The George Campbell YouTube show and
co-host of the smart money happy hour
with Rachel Cruz both very popular
Ramsay Network Productions be sure and
check them out on YouTube Spotify or
wherever else you view or listen to
Great podcasts and shows we're pretty
much everywhere we're
medium agnostic we go with everybody
wherever they'll take us you can show up
you can find us there yep wherever
they'll take us that's about right so
adjustable rate mortgages making a
comeback according to experian.com yeah
so I did this video on my YouTube
channel about a week ago and for some
reason it just blew up and people are
very interested in this idea with
mortgage interest rates being super high
right now and uh we have showed a stat
there in the very beginning at you know
January of 2022 it was like three
percent by May of 20 22 is 10 so we've
been seeing the spike in adjustable rate
mortgages and I want to get your 10 10
percent
uh online mortgage rights are 10 well no
the actual the amount of people doing
them oh three percent amount of people
doing adjustable rate mortgages has gone
way up yeah I got you okay yeah not the
interest rate itself okay so I wanted to
cover this and I just watched your real
estate lesson Financial Peace University
where you cover a lot of these mortgage
traps but a lot of people are going this
might be my ticket to home ownership
Dave and this article unpacks what's
going on here it's your ticket to
foreclosure yeah arms have started to
recover more from more than a decade of
disinterest from both consumers and
lenders they're returning to the fold
amid a sharp increase in home prices and
fixed mortgage rates that began in early
2022 as the housing market begins to
thaw from a year of depressed demand
more potential sellers begin to list
their homes could arms help more
prospective buyers get a foot in the
door of their first home understand this
this passive aggressive question
statement here is on Experian which is
this would be the credit bureau yeah
what is their vested interest in this
getting you in debt and keeping you in
debt because you're all worried about
their FICO score hello they'll make
money if you get a mortgage and they
have to run the score
this is a money-making scheme yeah we
love debt and so we're experiencing
we're gonna passively aggressively ask
is this a way for people to get their
foot in the door that sounded very soft
sounded like a suggestion to me sounded
like a conspiracy to me serious oh they
have a new stat in here Dave the share
increased from three percent it was for
the much of the decade to as high as 13
by October mortgages of the mortgage
Origins that are going out there three
percent used to be adjusted so 97 were
not doing adjustables and now 87 and
it's down as of April 2023 they say it's
now eight percent of all new mortgages
it's taking a dip so do we need to talk
about this well I want you to just share
why they're a bad idea because people
don't understand and there's a funny
clip from the office with Michael Scott
falling for one of these and he's like
well no it's a 30 and she's like no it's
10 over and so I wanted you just to run
the analysis on who is this for why are
people doing this why should they stay
away okay
um we'll get real technical to help you
but before we do that let's just say
this all right if you buy a mortgage
that adjusts
in an increasing interest rate
environment
what are you expecting it to adjust to
up well that's dumber than a rock on the
surface
interest rates are moving up and you're
buying a mortgage that allows them to
end and gives you the probability of a
higher interest rate later let's just
start with that's stupid
okay the second thing is this let's say
interest rates stay the same or go down
slightly
here's what you're going to discover
your mortgage interest on your
adjustable rate mortgage is going to go
up
even if rates go down a little or stay
the same
here's why your mortgage is adjusted
based on an index
and a spread over the index let's just
do a simplified version okay let's say
you took out a four percent adjustable
rate mortgage and it's supposed to be
two percent over the index that would
mean the index would be two
two plus two is four okay
and if the but the index however when
you start your brand new mortgage they
move you in on a bait and switch
because the index is already higher
would it would would give you the spread
would already give you a higher interest
rate today than you're getting today so
instead of the more okay let's say we're
getting a four percent adjustable rate
the index is two your spread is two so
that two plus two equals four okay but
it's not two the index today in that
case would be more like 2.6
um
so the interest rates would have to go
down 0.6 for your rate to remain the
same the next time it adjusts y'all
follow I'm doing this okay because the
index plus your spread equals your
interest rate and the index is already
cheated up when you go in so rates would
have to go down in order for you to do
this and so it's a big gamble so it's
not a big gamble more 100 and dead on
gonna have an increase there's no gamble
about it you're you know and you bought
the house on short-term thinking thank
God it's Friday oh God it's money I can
pay this payment like this payment's
even going to be around on the first
adjust you're going to see an increase
it's not a gamble almost a hundred
percent of the time because again rates
would have to go down to get your spread
to keep your spread on the end far
enough down okay it just doesn't work so
this all came from
mortgage companies protecting themselves
in 1982. I was selling real estate the
first adjustable rates came out then
okay because interest rates have gone to
17 percent
remember that and more and money market
rates back then we had these things
called savings and loans Money Market
rates on your savings were 12 percent
you could get 12 on your savings account
well let me help you with this the local
savings and loan makes a loan in the 70s
on a mortgage four percent
they are receiving four percent on a
hundred thousand dollars
interest rates shoot up that's a four
percent fixed rate loan
now in order to get a hundred thousand
dollars into the savings zone or into
the bank they got to pay out twelve but
they're only receiving four that's a
problem that's caught in a banking World
they call that disintermediation your
your butt's upside down mathematically
and so that's one of the things called
Savings and Loan industry to crash
that's why I brought up savings loans
it's one of the things that crashed them
was disintermediation it wasn't fraud it
was that
because they had millions of dollars of
mortgages on the books at a fixed rate
and all of a sudden they're having to
pay more than they're receiving to get
new savings deposits so they said to
themselves self I don't like this next
time these rates go up we're going to
have a portion of our portfolio that
adjusts up as interest rates go up and
so the adjustable rate mortgage was born
so that to protect the banks against an
increasing interest rate environment so
they don't get stuck with a bunch of low
interest mortgages on the books
ta-da the first and the first adjustable
rate mortgage I sold was the fixed rates
were 14 1982 1983
the fixed rates were 14 our adjustables
were 12.
and I said man nobody will ever buy
these things and that was 1982 and
they're still buying them still around
today so they're just transferring the
risk from the lender onto you 100 what
it does it transfers the risk of higher
interest rates from the lender it
ensures that the lender is always going
to freaking make money
this is a bank play it ain't got
anything to do with being a blessing to
you in allowing according to experience
help prospective buyers get their foot
in the door bull crap hadn't got
anything to do with prospective buyers
it's got to do with banks and one thing
you can count on banks is Banks
protecting Banks it's what they do and
they've been good at it for a long time
that's why their Furniture is nicer than
yours that's why their building is
bigger than yours
it's not an accident Santa Claus didn't
build those freaking Towers in the
skyline
it was you you built them with this kind
of crap where you give these Banks your
money you fall for the Trap of this
stuff so adjustable rate mortgages is
it's one of the biggest rip-offs ever to
come along especially because of the
motivation of it yeah it's become a lot
of inspiration everything so don't if
you have to do an adjustable rate
mortgage it means you can't afford the
house
that's what it means don't buy that
listen if you don't want your feelings
hurt go watch the YouTube version that I
did called the sneaky mortgage trap
people keep falling for I'm nicer than
Dave in the video I will say that much
George that's a hundred percent true
always and James
he plays the guitar in the video so
that's one more reason to go check it
out well there's just a lot of
entertainment value that's all I can
bring nice people with guitars okay
leave the Grouch alone this is the
Ramsay ship
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
Solutions on the debt-free stage Alec is
with us hey Alex how are you hey guys
how's it going better than we deserve
where do you live uh well I live in Los
Angeles right now but I will be moving
over here to Franklin next week oh wow
getting ready to be neighbors then yes
sir right next to you very cool love it
so uh how much data have you paid off
Alec uh the 73 and 636 dollars love it
and how long did that take about two and
a half years all right very good and
your range of income during that time so
I started out at 89 and closed out at
about 1 30. cool good for you love it so
what kind of debt was the 74 000 well it
was a combination of a few things I had
student loans which was probably about
53 and then I had a car loan which was
about 19 and then the rest was phones so
okay had a couple phones but all right
cool good deal I love it so um
good stuff now what got you started on
this two and a half years ago
um well it actually started a little bit
earlier than that my mom had got me uh
The Total Money Makeover book for
Christmas and uh she goes hey you know I
think you should get on this and you
know start working on it so I said uh
you know all right I'll get around to it
and then um covet kind of hit and uh
yeah yeah and uh covet hit and I started
doing Postmates and then I kept doing
that kept doing that and I'd racked up
probably like about six thousand dollars
and I was looking at my car one day and
I knew that I had the car note and I
basically told myself that either you
know I could put this in some
Investments or I could just really start
on this and I took that 6 000 that day
put it towards my car loan oh and just
kept ongoing so I got it started yes it
did saw the number go down you're like
this works like I can I can own this wow
and this was in LA yes during covid what
a brave soul you were I no not only I Am
Legend streets delivering food to people
oh my gosh I did some things I'm not
proud of driving through those streets
but uh it was done I do miss the lack of
traffic
oh my gosh
yeah I don't miss the reason for it but
I miss the lack of traffic what caused
your income to jump what do you do for
work well I work in construction and I
started out with a contractor out in LA
and then uh I you know wanted to switch
it up wanted to go on a different path
for my career took a job with another
contractor and obviously you know that
jumped my income but the big thing I did
want to say was you know I decided to
leave that company and come out here
because when I was just getting tired of
LA and uh for all the people that are
listening you know if you think you know
I come out here to Tennessee you know
I'm gonna take a paid jump because of
taxes number one that's true but my
salary actually didn't change so wow I'm
still making the same I I made in La out
here with not with no taxes with no
taxes so I got a paid jump
so there you go incredible just like
that just like that well done so it can
be done yeah good for you all right so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt-ish uh well I jotted
a couple things down but um you know I
wanted to keep it short and simple but
you know I was young when I got started
you know I'm 27 now so I got started
probably you know around when I was 25
uh 24 but uh you know start when you're
young if you get on this plan that Dave
has got out there you know we got the
baby steps and everything it's laid out
right there for you but I'll say you
know if you start when you're young you
can get ahead of yourself and you can
continue on that path to hopefully build
more wealth as time goes on
um but the big thing is is you know
you've got to want it when you're going
out with your friends you're out at the
bar you know and everybody's like hey
you gonna lay your card down so we can
get some shots nope I'm not
um but you know like that came up a
couple times for me so
that was not a very specific yeah that's
a tough one because people feel like
well I'm gonna miss out on my social
life in my prime years in my 20s and you
went hey I could sacrifice for two years
not gonna remember it anyway yeah they
have no recollection of this experience
oh yeah I again that's I won't go into
it but you know you can you can
definitely still have fun I will say
that my uh my roommate told me you know
you got to live your life
um you know you just have to live within
your means
um I definitely live below your means
like you mentioned Dave but now you're
really living with no payments I know it
I mean how does it feel to be free oh my
gosh it's just so uh freeing you know
but um relieving at the same time you
know now I can go in I got you know my
lovely fiance over here all right yeah
good news on the horizon there's one
reason to get your act together I know
yeah her parents were looking at me like
man you know you better get this stuff
going you know we uh yeah but um so
they're proud your mom's proud
everybody's proud you got to feel good I
feel great you know I feel really
privileged to be here with you guys well
we're honored to have you you're a hero
man you took control of your life and
you did it at 24 years old that's pretty
impressive that's very cool good for you
good for you because you got the rest of
your life now to live with common sense
as you're as your uh as your side mate
there well done and a great fiance to go
that's awesome very cool when are you
getting married have you decided uh well
like that last caller you know is still
well obviously we're you know engaged
but I think probably about two years is
what we're thinking there's a lot of uh
weddings next year so she just agreed
with that okay well she told me that oh
okay well you're already got that part
figured out okay good
good that's a good start right there
that and stuff so well done sir very
very well done what did you do did you
work in any extra I mean did you do
anything other than just the
construction or well as I said yeah just
the the Postmates is what I did that got
me started oh okay you kept doing that
yeah but um it was really just you know
saving money where I could uh with with
my income working in construction so
okay there's two ways to get that margin
spend less and make more you did a
little bit of both and you went oh my
gosh I got some money left over to throw
out the debt now oh yeah oh there's no
life hacks there no not just a wall
George yeah yeah well done sir proud of
you good good work very cool very cool
hey we've got the live and give box for
you and includes the baby steps
millionaires book it includes The Total
Money Makeover book and a Financial
Peace University membership any of those
that you haven't read or done do them
and give the rest of it away it's a live
and give bundle so uh thanks for coming
all the way out here and welcome to the
community is a new uh as a new neighbor
all right it's Alec temporarily from Los
Angeles 74
000 paid off in two and a half years
making 89 to 130. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream all right here
we go three two one I'm debt free
yeah
that's how that's done
boom wow gotta love it
you gotta love it
you know it is always interesting to me
George that
um I I don't know what the percentage is
I don't know if we've ever actually done
the number but I'll anecdotally say it's
in the 90 plus range of the debt-free
screams during the time they're getting
out of debt have an increase in income
sometimes it's a temporary increase
because they pick up extra jobs
sometimes it's just they're looking
around and going if I lived over there I
wouldn't have any taxes you know if I
live over there I'd have that you know
and so they get an increase in income
because they're paying attention uh too
many times two if one part of our life
is on uh Coast mode you know we're just
sliding along then another part of our
life so in other words if we're letting
our we're half but paying attention to
our money we may be half paying
attention to our career and when you
start looking at I need to get out of
this debt well how do I do that why I
don't have some more money then you
start looking at your career going I
don't make enough this is crazy I gotta
change something yeah well I've been
changed jobs they change careers they
add extra jobs and we see income go up
when people start paying attention well
a lot of people in their 20s they just
feel like they're kind of a victim to
the career culture and they're a
passenger in this car that they have no
effect on their income but once they
believe they can pay off debt they also
believe I can go make more money and
that's the most inspiring thing is you
know people like Alec realize oh hope is
a choice just as much as cynicism is a
choice I can wait on the government I
can complain inflation the housing
market and wages have they haven't gone
up as fast as inflation and it's
everyone else's fault and Alex just went
yep and I'm going to do something about
it and that is the key indicator I found
between the YouTube commenters and the
Alex of the world and so that's a great
reminder for everyone out there cynicism
is a choice hope is a choice you get to
choose Oh you mean the negative
commenter yes some of them are kind but
yeah those are the generic YouTube
comments gone this guy's out of touch
nobody can do this Alec did it he's just
like you yeah and we're so weird we talk
to people every day that do it and if we
don't we talk somebody into doing it
that's right this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Matt is with
us in Detroit hey Matt welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey everyone how's it going better than
we deserve what's up excellent so I uh I
called the show I think maybe a week or
two ago and I spoke with George and Dave
uh George and Jade and I gave my
situation and the recommendation was to
pay off my house and pay off my my car
with the remaining balance so that we
hand our savings and my wife and I
decide to do that and honestly there's a
gigantic waitlisted off our shoulders
we're completely debt free Wow way to go
I don't know if you remember that called
Uh George I have it's coming back to me
we are thinking about upgrading our
house right and but we didn't really
need to right now we're kind of in that
sweet spot it feels like it's getting a
little bit smaller on us but I think we
still have some time so we decided to
just pay off our house pay off our car
we're completely debt free right now
incredible I know it's amazing it feels
so okay honestly uh everyone that I've
listened to especially from you guys you
always say it's just you'll be able to
sleep in I have never slept better well
as best as I can with uh two boys at
home but my next question is or my
question is now where do I go from here
so we're thinking about looking into
financial planners and I guess my
question is what are some good questions
to ask them and how do I find one that's
going to work for me and not you know
just work for a paycheck basically and
you know someone has my best interests
in mind
good for you well um the one you can
count on always having your best
interest in mind is you
so uh never acquiesce your decision
making to someone else so your financial
planners uh a percentage of them I don't
know maybe 80 percent are sales people
that is not what you want the other
percentage are teachers they have the
heart of a teacher the teacher gives you
the information and assumes you're a
grown-up and you get to make your own
decisions with your own money they're
going to teach you something you're
going to learn you're going to feel
equipped to make your own decision not I
did this because my guy said to do it
and I have no freaking idea what I just
did
which is how athletes lose all their
money right
absolutely yeah so you need a somewhat
the main thing you want is someone with
the heart of a teacher the second thing
you want is someone whose values align
with what you believe to be true about
the world for instance you have just
discovered that debt-free is awesome if
you walked in and sat down with a
financial planner and they say oh no you
should go take out a 400 000 mortgage
and use that money to invest with me if
that doesn't make you run out of there
with your hair on fire something's wrong
with you
absolutely and that we have something
scheduled so that's kind of what I had
in mind we my wife and I have specific
goals and plans especially with saving
for the kids
so that's exactly what I was so they
need to execute your plan not give you
theirs
absolutely that's that's really yeah
really good and if you want people to do
this stuff the way we teach we call them
smart Vester Pros there are thousands of
them around the nation that we have
vetted and they have the heart of a
teacher and they believe and have the
same values that we teach here on the
air you can find one of those a
smartvester pro by clicking smartvestor
at uh ramsesolutions.com it'll drop down
a drop down box and you can pick from
one or all of the ones on the drop down
box and go and interview them and find
one that fits you and your personality
best yeah and the other thing to think
about here it's it's not just about a
lot of people go well if it's just
choosing funds then I can go figure that
out on my own and do DIY but when you
think about the value of financial
advisor and vanguard's even done studies
on this to show that the average
investor doing it on their own they
don't make as much as those working with
a pro the ones working with the pro are
making three percent more over the
lifetime and so you want to think about
tax planning estate planning kind of
that big high level financial plan not
just the 529 plan yeah hey
congratulations Matt we're so happy for
you good job great place to be I don't
you never know if people actually take
the advice we give and so it's just good
to know true sometimes well sometimes we
know they're not going to yeah but
imagine I can tell he was like okay I'm
listening and so I appreciate that Matt
I'm proud he went and did it and you
know back to that Vanguard study one of
the other reasons we find that um people
make more with a financial advisor is
simply because they don't jump in and
out of the market based on emotion they
try to time the market I'm going to get
in because it's going up I'm going to
get out because it's going down now you
just stay in
and part of a good advisor's job is talk
you off the ledge and keep you invested
don't stop investing and don't cash in
and try to jump in jump out and I'm
going to time the market there's tons of
research that shows that market timing
doesn't work it doesn't keep up with
simply staying invested those on a
roller coaster ride that don't jump off
in the middle of the ride do not get
hurt
ride the sucker write it down
and then write it up click click click
click click click click click click
enjoy the whole thing it's part of the
deal so that's what you want to do in
this thing and you know getting an
advisor in your corner is a big deal
Elijah's in Connecticut hey Elijah
what's up
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up how can we help
so I got a little
bit of bad news so uh good news is my
wife and I expecting baby number three
yay
yeah pretty exciting and bad news is uh
we're outgrowing our house
um so we're kind of thinking of what the
next step is for us
um so we're looking at a couple options
one is obviously selling and buying a
new house
um the second one is probably renting
this house and buying a new one no and
the third one we're really taking a
close look at is
um remodeling uh this would allow us to
basically convert our renovated attic
into a full floor that would add two
bedrooms and a bathroom
um so yeah I just wanted to get some
input in terms of that I can give you
some um you know background in terms of
our finances too so are you out of debt
uh yeah everything besides our mortgage
uh so I would move today I would sell
your house and move
okay all right a lot of reasons a lot of
reasons for that quality of life during
a remodel is horrible and you got a
pregnant wife or a brand new baby you're
talking about doing this with no thank
you
I don't want to do a remodeling that
second thing is is you're probably I
don't even ask you the numbers yet but
you're probably getting ready to
overbuild the neighborhood
you're gonna have a house that's too
expensive for that neighborhood you'll
never get your money out and so uh
you're trying to you're trying to force
a square peg into a round hole how big
is how many square feets the house
you're in
it's about 1700 yeah
okay and the average square footage of
the house on your street is what
uh they're all about that size
yeah I mean a little bigger I'd say
no I don't think it would be out of
place if we added a second floor okay
you don't think you would over build the
neighborhood
no no no actually like there's a lot of
new construction new construction
doesn't count what's that call unless
your house is like three years old
right right so uh the cost of renovating
would probably be close to 200 000. oh
move for God's sakes move it's easier to
build a house than do a 200 000
renovation
net net worth what's your house worth
oh the house
um about 450 000 we owe about 180 on it
so you're saying houses in that
neighborhood go from 450 to 650 bull
crap no they don't
yeah I mean further down the street
they're like you know you're stretching
man to the beach people don't drive on
your street looking for 650 000 houses
you're stretching
yeah you're building you're over
building the neighborhood I promise you
I've been doing this my whole life real
estate's my thing man no you're getting
ready to screw this up and I got to tell
you you have no idea the hell you're
getting ready to embrace with a 200 000
rehab it's gonna take more time and even
more money than you thought with more
problems it's an easier to push the
whole dad blame thing down start over my
God it really is it's just a heart it's
a whole lot easier to build a house into
a rehab that size oh man no I and and
little babies already and this is the
third one coming in no thank you have a
quality of life don't you know how much
emotional bandwidth you're going to
invest in this crap by the time you're
done in the middle of having a baby no
no no no no no no no you know you you
shouldn't build a house this year either
by the way same thing emotional
bandwidth now just go buy you a nice
house for 650 000 or less where the
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed and
make your move up please
sell that one you're in don't try to
stand don't become a landlord by default
with a bunch of debt just keep it real
simple and real clean man your life is
just going to be so much better
oh you don't want the hassle oh man no
thank you this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today this hour is a baby steps
Millionaire's theme hour for those of
you that are new to us that means we're
going to talk only to millionaires this
hour the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you're a millionaire we want to get some
of the details on your life and your
story so that other people can hear how
to do what you have done see there's a
lot of people out there with opinions
about wealth that don't have any
wealth they got lots of opinions they
got no money
and if broke people are giving you their
opinion on money that's kind of dumb if
you're listening anyway and so you don't
want to do that you want to talk to real
people and I don't really care about
your broke brother-in-law who votes
wrong I don't need his opinion
I just you know so oh money I mean if
you want to talk to him about something
else that's fine I'm not mad at him but
I'm not going to do this so here let's
start with the basic definition of what
a millionaire is George A Millionaire is
not someone that makes a million dollars
a year
thank you for clearing that up that's a
misconception a lot of people have yeah
and a millionaire is not someone that
has a million dollars cash
that's a cash millionaire no so not a
network this is not it's like the word
recession there is a technical
definition for it and you don't get to
make it up well I think we're in a
recession I don't care what you think a
recession is two consecutive quarters of
a shrinking GDP period it's an economic
definition it's not a political term and
you don't get to decide if we're in one
or not all you can do is observe the
actual numbers you don't get to decide
if you're a millionaire you don't get to
redefine millionaire to fit your little
political agenda and your equal your
wealth equality communism Marxism crap
so here here's what you get here's what
a millionaire is it is when someone has
a net worth of one million dollars or
greater
period
that's it there's not another definition
well he's a net worth millionaire that's
the only kind of millionaires there is
it's not it's redundant it's redundant
it's like he's a millionaire millionaire
okay that's what you're saying all right
so a millionaire is someone whose assets
minus their liabilities equals a million
dollars or greater what you own minus
what you owe equals a million dollars
well you can't count real estate yes you
can it's an asset stupid
in the YouTube comments Dave when I tell
people I walk them through how to do
this they go you can't count your house
you can't even count your retirement
accounts because you can't live off of
that right now that's just dumb you can
you can't count it if you want to do a
risk analysis A liquidity analysis but
to determine if you're a millionaire
there's only one method assets minus
liabilities equals a million dollars or
greater so that's who we want to talk to
and we want to find out how you did it
we're going to start with Craig in
Milwaukee Craig what's your net worth
just shy of 1.7 million love it okay
give me a little breakdown by category
on that how much of retirement how much
is house and so on
um just about 700 000 in retirement and
529 accounts about 550
000 in a mix of cash and other
Investments ETF stocks T bills trading
bonds even even a little precious metals
and
um and then about 450 000 in real estate
which is made up of our primary
residence got it how old are you
on 51 my wife is 45. cool and how much
of this 1.7 million did you inherit
zero zero okay and what was your in your
working lifetime what was your work best
year working income and your worst year
working income
over 200
000 and the worst was
um maybe 70 80 000 okay and what do you
do for a living or did you do for a
living
uh-huh okay so obviously you have a law
degree all right what was your GPA
uh in law school it was uh just about
3.0 okay good for you cool so uh if
you're talking to the younger version of
yourself 25 years ago in their 20s can a
young lawyer still become a millionaire
yes
what would they do what would you tell
them to do well I I think uh
I would recommend you know take the time
to to know yourself and
um you know if you're you're going to
get married uh choose a spouse who
shares your views on money and finance
among other things because in my
experience uh that became very very
critically important and uh you know not
to go off on a tangent but we we uh
we're introduced to to you know your
money management Concepts very early in
our marriage and we really took to them
and we paid off
um student loan debt we sit for a house
but we took on a huge mortgage and
ultimately became unhappy with our
lifestyle felt like we strayed from the
money management principles that that
you teach and that we are following and
so we decided to make a radical change
in solar house and move to where we
currently live and and now we're living
the exact life we want to live um and if
my my wife wasn't on the same page with
me about that that could be very
challenging so I would recommend that
and other than that I think very
standard things that you hear all the
time uh live beneath your means I would
say be resourceful
and be content with what you've got now
and be patient because tomorrow
um typically tomorrow is a better day
and in the long term it's going to be
much much better A lot of wisdom there
Craig I'm curious what car are you
driving right now as a net worth
millionaire
and right now I drive a 2008 Honda Pilot
wow what's she drive
she drives a 2019
Volkswagen Atlas good man she's got the
nicer car
that's awesome I love it well
congratulations sir you're a hero I'm
proud of you you went out there and did
something that most lawyers don't do
however I will tell you that in the
larger study of millionaires ever done
in North America done by Ramsey research
team a couple years ago we had the top
five career Fields number five that that
most often became millionaires number
five was lawyer wow and the average age
I believe was 51 yeah this guy's he's
like a case study and they drove Honda
and Teo about a third of his net worth
is his real estate he's investors it's
just exactly a case study he's like a
template of the averages of that study
we studied over 10 167 millionaires so
the conclusions we came to in that study
are what's known as facts so if you
disagree with them you're what's known
as wrong
that's how that works okay we'll help
you with this it's a millionaire a baby
steps Millionaire's theme hour we put
all of this together in the book The
Baby Steps millionaire and became a
number one bestseller so be sure and
check that out as well George Campbell
is with us we'll be talking to real
millionaires call us if you're one the
number is 888-825-5225
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER George camel Ramsay personality is my
co-host today we started doing this
theme hour on millionaires several years
ago it led us to do a study of
millionaires and the white paper of that
study is in the back of the uh if you
want the detail the nerdy research parts
of it's in the back of the book The Baby
ships millionaires book you can find it
there but we started doing the show
because I kept running into millionaires
and they weren't what everyone said they
were because I didn't grow up with money
I grew up regular guy just like George
you know regular guy and you know I just
because I became a millionaire I thought
well maybe some of the you know because
here's the things people say about
millionaires okay they say stuff like
well they all inherited their wealth
you can't be a millionaire if you don't
have a jungle right they always say that
you know millionaires are the only way
to get money is be a crook
she must have stolen they did something
wrong
you can't get that rich without doing
something wrong right or they the other
perception is is that all millionaires
all wealthy people you have to be famous
you know you have to be like a country
music star a rock star a professional
athlete a Hollywood actor
and the other thing they think is that
they're okay I can't be a millionaire
because I'm not brilliant I'm not a 4.0
4.2 GPA guy investing Guru I don't have
this I don't have this Special Sauce I'm
just a regular guy regular gal and
that's the four biggest mythologies that
are out there and what we found with the
study was and we first found it when
we're just talking to millionaires here
on the air is that all four of those are
lies
none of them are true
very seldom to Crooks become
millionaires
let me help you with this because when
Crooks rip somebody off
you know what people do they tell
everybody
and nobody does business with a crook
anymore
if you go to a
you know I'll tell you a lot of
millionaires are they own auto repair
stores
a lot of millionaires auto repair stores
and uh you think they're just somebody
turns a wrench but I just tell you they
got more money than you got and so
um
so but if you go in there that guy's
story and he rips you off I'm repairing
your car you know he puts in a he claims
to fix it charges you a thousand dollars
and you drive off and it's still doing
it right still got a problem you come
back he goes well I guess you know it's
the way it is and you know whatever it
was it was an analysis fee and what do
you do you tell everybody that guy that
guy's a crook they're going on Yelp
Google reviews
yeah exactly you go over that same auto
repair guy and he says you go in there
and he does three things he comes out
and you go if he goes I got it fixed
there's no problem you go what do you
what do I owe you nothing it didn't cost
me anything you just took a minute go
ahead just just remember me later well
you tell everybody you found an honest
car repair guy so Crooks don't become
rich that's just a dadgum Mythology by
rednecks with poor mouthing you know
that's the ones I grew up little man
can't get ahead
life is rough people like us you ever
hear these people like Eeyore is their
spirit animal
you hear them people yeah well that
that's the ones tell you crooks are all
rich people all rich people are Crooks
well bullcrap almost no rich people are
Crux
most of them are some of the more honest
people you ever run into that's how they
got rich dummy
they they got a reputation for doing it
right and bringing it you know golly
this is silly all right let's go to
Sarah in San Francisco Sarah what's your
net worth
um about 2.6 million cool and how much
of that did you steal
I'm kidding I couldn't resist after that
last little round okay so give me a
little breakdown by category
um my home is worth about eight hundred
thousand which is all paid off I have a
vacation property in Mexico that they
owe about 50 000 on it's worth about 700
000. good for you
um I have about
1.2 million in
um
401K cash and other things
very good well done what where are you
in Mexico with that vacation property
what city Cabo Cabo San Lucas good for
you fun very cool all right how old are
you
63. cool and how much of this did you
inherit
I did actually inherit are at about five
hundred thousand but I have not touched
that right I don't want to take any
money out because I don't want to pay
taxes on it but I haven't I haven't
really used that for anything is that in
the 2.6
yes okay and how much of that did that
come after you were already a
millionaire or before you were a
millionaire
um
well when you received it did you
already have a million dollar net worth
or not
part of it maybe
okay so this helped make you a
millionaire okay good okay so you did
inherit part of it that's good all right
now so your income range your best
you're working and your worse you're
working
my best
professional
in the last 20 years probably around 20
000. okay cool what do you what'd you do
for a living what was your career
um I am a physician
physics got it okay and so obviously
you've got a PA degree and what was your
what was your GPA
um probably around 3.3 good for you okay
cool all right you're talking I I met a
young PA on a trip I was on the other
day
um he was in his 20 well I guess he's in
his early 30s but if you're talking to a
young PA in their 20s or 30s can they
still do this could they still become
worth 2.6 million even if they didn't
inherit to half a million
oh definitely yes listen to Dave Ramsey
and
2 401K property don't buy stupid things
and invest your money
wow rocket science
that's impressive and you just did that
over a long period of time you said over
the last how many years do you think
you've really been kind of on a good
financial plan
actually not that long
16 years I
was on careers I was a firefighter the
first part of my life and then I got
injured so I had to reinvent myself so I
went back to PA school I got very sick
right after I graduated
and then I almost lost my house so
almost all of this has been in the last
16 years wow good for you well this has
not been easy yeah and you're 63. and
the future is bright
yes and the sun shining in Cabo
it sounds like you can work because you
want to and not because you have to
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah I love my
job now because I don't have to work and
I don't have to work as much
so that is rare you can do anything you
want all right do you read more books or
watch more TV are you a book person or a
Netflix person
oh I don't watch TV there's too much
life I was in bed for two years so I'm
not watching TV no I'd rather go out and
enjoy friends and family and
life there we go right there words from
a millionaire 63 years old 2.6 million
dollar net worth very very well done by
the way the statistics on inheriting the
money
um as we discovered when we were the
reason I was asking her the questions
the way they were is it fits the
research that we did
79 of America's millionaires with the
largest study airtight research
of America's millionaires ever done
79 received an inheritance of zero
five percent received a very small
inheritance like granny left him five
grand so mathematically they were not
millionaires because they got an
inheritance another five percent like
her received a substantial inheritance
but did so after they were already
millionaires now that part was not like
her this hers situation literally she
did become get her first million because
of an inheritance so she actually is one
of the rare ones but five percent a
little bit five percent after
already Millionaires and 79 percent zero
those three figures added together is 89
percent 79 plus five plus five that's
nine out of ten of America's
millionaires are not millionaires
because of inherited money
what's that mean number one it means the
Communists out there telling you
otherwise are lying number two it means
you have a chance
she started 16 years ago she's 63. now
she did get an inheritance that helped
her but she's basically done most of her
wealth building in the last little bit
this is a baby steps millionaire hour on
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
ER George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host
Dawn is our next millionaire in Kenton
Ohio Don what's your net worth my net
worth is 2.24 million cool give me a
little breakdown by category
well retirement accounts we've got 1.9
million there most of that's in company
stocks that own about 98 different
companies there and then also some
mutual funds and that's all spread out
in Roth and traditional I've got 66 000
in HSA and
um 45 000 in in cash in the bank our
homes worth somewhere around 170 and
personal property around 30 000. wow
good for you so most of this is a
retirement account then yeah wow yeah
good for you how old are you
cool all right and how much of this did
you inherit
none zero and what was your best year
working income and your worst year
working income
uh my best year would have been uh an
outlier I made uh about uh 148 that year
a big turnaround at the refinery and
then uh way back in 1980 I was making
about 19 000. okay cool cool what was
your career
an electrician I started out as a union
electrician in the construction industry
and and then 15 years after that I moved
into the refining industry so you did on
an apprenticeship rather than a
four-year degree I assume yes it's an
apprenticeship all right cool cool so
high school graduate then right
right good for you good for you well
done what was your GPA in high school do
you remember
girls uh it could have been better I'd
be the best dancer so far all right I'm
writing that one down I like that all
right it was probably in in the three
range somewhere it uh I had the capacity
to do much better but uh had
distractions along the way yeah I've
heard about those you didn't apply
yourself that's what we call it yeah all
right so you're talking to a young guy
who's heading into the trades gonna be a
plumber gonna be an electrician he's 23
25 years old and he's listening right
now and I promise you he's listening uh
can he still become a millionaire in
America today based on your knowledge
he can uh but he needs to invest or he
needs to budget first of all do all
those Basics because you got to have
some Headroom left uh so you have
something to invest and you know I
messed around until I was 37. I didn't
start this till I was 37 years old so I
had to do a lot of catching up
so what you're telling him is is he
could have five to ten million if he
starts at 25. exactly he'd have a whole
lot more than what I've done yeah wow
yeah well done sir you're a hero proud
of you so what what any other advice you
would give to the listener out there
that thinks you can't be a millionaire
today or wants to know how to do it
well
um you know stop playing around with
with all the things that don't get you
anywhere like the credit card points and
and things like that they're just
totally meaningless uh the biggest thing
in our uh family would be uh tithing and
honoring God with tithes and offerings
and that's very big for us and and uh we
think that the Bible does tell us that
uh that a rich man can get into the
kingdom of God as long as he honors God
puts him first turns it all over to him
and and uh operates in his principles
amen
um another thing is is what helped me
over the years I think the most was just
staying invested uh time in the market
and being invested in in equities uh and
just being consistent that's that's
really where I got where I was going I
I'm not a genius but I think I just did
this did the things uh correctly there I
don't know if you're a genius or not but
I think you're very he wise and I'm very
impressed very very well done Danielle
is our next millionaire in Hartford
Connecticut Danielle what's your net
worth
my net worth is
1.375 million got it and uh I'm gonna
call it 1.4 okay and give me a little
breakdown by category please
sure it's about 187 000 in cash about
256 000 a brokerage account
um about 789
000 in retirement and I own a condo
that's worth about 250 000.
good for you well done how old are you
46 you're single
yes cool and how much of this did you
inherit
none of it okay and uh what was your
best year working income so far and your
worst year working income so far
175 with bonus it brings me up to a
little over two worst year was probably
when I started out of college so I think
I started off around 32 000 a year cool
what's your career
I am a procurement systems manager so I
manage a team of systems analysts that
run um the applications that support our
procurement division got it so your
degree information systems or what
in healthcare I went to school for
health administration but I somehow
ended up in the insurance capital of the
world so uh that's where I reside right
now yeah definitely okay so what was
your GPA in school
three four eight three four eight all
right cool all right and um wow good for
you so same question uh the younger
version of you is listening out there
can they still do this and if they can
what should they do
without a doubt they can do it um I
think they just need to
[Applause]
make a big job I invested 10 annually
it's my 401k and just budget you know
growing up my parents always taught us
to distinguish between our wants versus
our needs right and you know I don't
replace things frequently I run them
until they break and you know set aside
discretionary income to do the things
you enjoy but also set aside things for
you know rainy day and just be very
disciplined and be cautious
hmm that'll preach I'm curious Danielle
what car do you drive at 46 with a net
worth of 1.4 million
[Music]
there we go what year is it
it's a 2016. all right
fantastic so like every other
millionaire we talked to everyone with
past you in traffic and have no idea
trust me I would love to have a really
nice vehicle but it's just not worth it
it's a waste of money and it's just you
know I'd rather invest it into real
estate I mean like I do I I do have 105
000 left on my mortgage but the goal is
to eventually buy a house
um and that's really where I'm saving my
money to go yeah you're doing a great
job you're a hero impressive so proud of
you thank you for sharing your story
most people are broke making 50 Grand a
year buying sixty thousand dollar cars
and Danielle's like ah cars aren't worth
it I got 300 000 in cash I'm not it's
not worth buying a new car so take it
from actual millionaires they don't do
that kind of stuff now the other thing
you need to distinguish folks is the
difference in a billionaire and a
millionaire I'll talk about this in the
baby steps Millionaire's book I did a
whole chapter on it because sometimes
people think of a think of a millionaire
as being a billionaire millionaires do
not have private jets
period okay they do not drive
Lamborghinis
they don't have the money to okay it's
only a million dollars
you know do private jets for a million
bucks okay there's no there's not one of
those and if you do it's a freaking
antique okay
I'm not riding in that thing so uh and
you know Lamborghinis and 250 000 cars
that kind of stuff that that's not you
know seven cars uh three vacation homes
around the world a Mountain Home a beach
home or whatever a glacoma the
millionaires billionaires can do that
but a billion is a thousand million
you're a thousand a millionaire that's a
lot different than being a millionaire
and so if you hear somebody's got seven
cars five six houses they've got a
private jet they're probably approaching
or you know should at least Deca
millionaire that'll be well beyond
that'll be on Beyond Deca but anyway but
yeah they're north of probably 50
million at least and heading towards a
thousand million
and you know a billion billionaires
that's not gonna get there in your 401k
but there's not as many build there's a
lot there's about a 12 million
millionaires in America
there's not that many billionaires
billionaires are a lot less that's for
sure so I and it is a different formula
and a different setup so when you think
of millionaires well you know nobody
needs that much money this is not a
moral construct it's a math thing assets
minus liabilities equals a million it's
the only definition well it's not enough
money we can discuss that but that's not
how you decide if you're a millionaire
or not we're talking to real
Millionaires and asking them how they
got there it's a baby steps
Millionaire's theme hour
[Music]
all right
our scripture of the day Proverbs 13 11
wealth obtained from nothing dwindles
but one who gathers by labor increases
it
Will Rogers said the quickest way to
double your money is fold it in half and
put it back in your pocket
it's a baby steps Millionaire's theme
hour we're talking to real millionaires
Matthew is one in Sarasota Florida
Matthew what's your net worth
right around 1.8 million good for you
give me a little breakdown by category
yep so we got about 600 Grand in
retirement 550 in a separate brokerage
account a hundred thousand in cash about
50 000 vehicles and houses probably
about five and a quarter good for you
well done cool how old are you
38 good and how much of this did you
inherit
none of it zero and your best working
year income and your worst working your
income
oh first five years of our marriage
probably around 70 75 000 and then got
into real estate 100 commission and
their best year was a little over 500.
oh you're killing it good for you well
done so your real estate guy if you got
a four-year degree
I do yeah I got a finance degree in
finance I set you up all right good good
and your GPA and your Finance degree was
what
um probably about 3.3 Okay cool so what
do you attribute the fact that you're a
millionaire too by the age of 38 what do
you what do you say people say how'd you
do that what's the key what are you
talking about 500 000 income doesn't
hurt
yeah so I mean obviously that helps but
I would say listen to you I probably
started in my early 20s and uh that set
us up in a way that I could take that
leap in a real estate
100 commission not knowing what we're
going to make and uh kind of weather
that storm in the beginning
good good for you okay cool so if a
younger version of you uh is listening
what are you telling me can it be done
still what's your philosophy on this
yep definitely could be done just um be
content with what you have and and uh
you know save it like you do and follow
the plan and it gets there yeah
you sound like you're just it's like a
matter of fact
yeah yeah do you ever have any emotions
about this when you hear these people
saying that America's too broken to win
and that anarchy is necessary and wealth
inequality is crazy and it's unfair out
there do you ever hear all that stuff
yeah yeah I've been listening to show so
I hear it all the time and I see it on
the news but um just kind of keep doing
what we've been doing for a while and
it's been working out for us just ignore
the noise
you create your own reality well it's
impressive because a lot of people that
are younger they're going well I can't
wait till 60 to have retirement so
therefore what's the point investing
they have a very Doom and Gloom but
you're 38 and you did this stuff it's
all well done Matthew proud of you man
Kerry is in Kansas City Kerry what's
your net worth
uh 1.5 million good for you and give me
a little breakdown by category
uh 530
000 in the house 450 and 401ks IRAs and
ESOP
475 in taxable brokerage account and
then 45 in cash cool how old are you
uh 34. oh our youngest of the day
excellent good for you how much of this
did you inherit
uh we did not inherit any of it zero and
what's your worst year income working
and best year income since you've been
working
about forty five thousand dollars when
we got out of school and since we've
been married and combined the 350 000.
cool what do you do for a living
so I'm a project director for McCarthy
building companies and my wife is a
neonatal nurse practitioner okay so a
nurse and you said you're a product
director
uh Project Director project oh I got you
okay okay I got you okay before you shut
out of school what was your degree in
I was construction management and Liz
went to nursing school she was nursing
of course yeah okay and your uh your uh
GPA and when you were in school
I was at I was at 3.5 and Liz was at a
4-0 uh through her graduate of course
she was
all right so you're a millionaire 1.5
million at 34 years old how did you do
that
I'd say consistency
um and really setting goals
um I mean I can't say I did the same
thing when I was younger my teens but
that was kind of the breaking point for
me of just not wanting to live paycheck
to paycheck so again setting goals and
being consistent
um saying no to some of those things
that don't carry a lot of value in our
life and
um as you get married just being being
on the same team the same page goes a
long way so the force multiplier there
yeah
well you've done this in a fairly short
period of time so obviously the answer
to the question can this still be done
you would say yes I assume
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely yeah
so uh do you guys watch more TV or read
more books
um I I listen to the podcast quite a bit
and um read more articles than chapter
books but it was uh she reads more of
the chapter books
of course we have our favorite shows
here and there but
well I'm really impressed did you have a
strategy going into this you know when
you were 24 were you like hey we want to
get to a million by this age and here's
how we're going to do it or whether was
it just these practices that landed you
there
I really didn't start listening to the
show until about four four or five years
ago
um but kind of instilled from my my dad
as far as just you know saving money and
just be intentional with it but when I
was able to to listen to the show and it
really got me on track with a plan to
get out of debt and then you kind of
carried that through to be able to pay
off the house on it too and just kind of
kept that focus and it just it feels
really good yeah
uh 2013 Lincoln MKX okay
cool what about uh what about your nurse
wife
uh she's in a uh Acura uh MDX yeah but
certified pre-owned perfect good very
good well deserved what an amazing
couple you guys are heroes well done all
right George just to make sure the
mythology is destroyed the gpas are 3.0
3.3 3.0 3.48 3.3 4.0 and a 3.5 so
there's no Geniuses but there's also no
dummies
so I don't ever get 1.7 and I play beer
pong you know I don't get that I get uh
you know I generally get around a 3.0
and that's the what the research shows
too
um inherited uh one two three four
inherited five inherited nothing one
inherited a half million that caused her
to be a millionaire so one out of five
today uh and the statistics are uh one
out of ten nationally we kept the calls
going we probably have more zeros yeah
and the net worth on the people calling
in they were not 50 million uh but these
are actual millionaires not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion 1.7
million dollar net worth 2.6 2.24 1.4
1.8 1.5 almost all of them it's a major
mix between their retirement and their
home uh very seldom was there anything
else weird in there we didn't hear any
crypto we didn't hear any uh Lotto uh we
didn't hear anything like that there's
nothing going on here real estate cash
and investment some of them did have
some company stocks but yeah is that
simple and I didn't talk to any famous
entertainers or athletes or
um you know so they didn't inherit it
they're not Crooks they're not famous
they don't have super high gpas they're
just people that work the system just
worked a plan and they did it over and
after the average by the way is about 17
years and these people in here were
talking that guy there many of them said
that he got serious four years ago
another one was 16 years ago since she
got hurt on the fire department remember
that and all that and so what these are
regular people an electrician a PA a
physician's assistant an attorney a
procurement a guy a real estate nurse
project manager for construction company
I didn't hear brain surgeon in there
or um nuclear engineer was not like an
entrepreneur that owns their own
business making a bajillion dollars I
didn't hear anybody I took a company
public now they all got their income up
they're all racing dual income they all
are learners but they and they all 100
believe not only it can it be done but
it should be done so proud of you guys
amazing baby steps millionaires female
if you want to know more about that pick
up the book The Baby Steps millionaires
it's the latest number one I did
and the only reason I did it was because
a bunch of you said it couldn't be done
so we proved to you that it can be done
and you're wrong don't tempt Dave with a
good time and a challenge that's it that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsey Baby Steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]